in the most talked about game in America
Drew has taken on many
challenges she's gone one on-one with
late night legend Jimmy Fallon she has
faced off with Fearless First Lady
Michelle
Obama we're kicking things off with a
game that will put taste buds to the
test and only one person will be left
standing from those doors a new
Challenger shall emerge Drew is about to
go head-to-head with the one the only
Chrissy
[Applause]
Tegan and today's host Ross
Matthews okay hi hi hi hi hi hi hi hi
it's chy t I and it's time everyone for
the game who knew don't
spew I'm going you take your white and
go that X right down there all walk you
through go right down there to the X
perfect your
X okay it's time to play now since
you're both cookbook authors I'm going
to be asking you food themed trivia
questions you'll answer at the same time
using your whiteboards which you each
have right now okay for every wrong
answer you each have to take a step
closer to this box now whoever reaches
the last Circle first has to eat
whatever is under this box and trust me
we've done our research it is both of
your worst
nightmare is the audience ready to see
what's underneath this
box let's take a
look it is go
cheese and every time I say what it is
we'll hear this sound goat
cheese we have a tower brimming with
stinky stinky goat
cheese doesn't it look good enough to
eat no no no meanwhile our audience has
a chance to win a not so nasty prize
Chrissy you are playing for the left
side of our audience
sorry meanwhile Drew you are playing for
the right side of our
Audience Show where I got this and
whoever wins their side of the audience
might just go home with a
prize but first it's time to get serious
are you both ready to play yes okay
question number one true or false
avocados are fruit write down your
answer on your whiteboard it's time to
reveal your answer at the same time go
Chrissy you say true Drew you say true
it is
true so you both can remain at home base
question number two what is the only
fruit with seeds on the
outside only fruit with seeds on the
outside here's a hint it's not Ross
Matthews all right it's time to reveal
your questions right
now Chrissy says strawberry Drew says
strawberry the answer is
[Applause]
strawberry it's time for question number
three what nut is used to make
marzipan marzipan used in desserts made
with a nut what nut is it okay let's
reveal our answers
now Drew says hazelnut Chrissy says
pistachio you guys are always in sync
and guess what you are again cuz you're
both
wrong the answer is almonds each of you
take a step closer to the goat Che oh my
gosh that's so obvious now here's
question number four what is the name of
this
fruit Drew seems to know she's thinking
it's time to reveal what fruit is this
this fruit angers me wrong go Chrissy
says dragon fruit you're right Drew says
kiwi
Chrissy Chrissy is Right Drew is very
wrong here's the next question what
condiment was used as medicine in the
1800s a very popular condiment it was
used as medicine in the
1800s they're both writing down their
answers and it's time to reveal them now
which condiment was used as medicine in
the 1800s Drew Chrissy go okay Chrissy
you say mustard I'm going to tell you
that is in
incorrect which means you need to take a
step closer to the ghost cheese
now Drew you wrote down syrup if you're
correct we have a tie game if you're
wrong you are the one who's eating the
goat
cheese the answer
is ketchup I was going
ketchup you so close must Drew Step
Closer You you are the one eating our
goat cheese we were so kmic do you want
me to eat it with you really yeah we'll
do it together cuz our brains were like
on the same level chissy oh Chrissy's
going to do it with her how cute thank
you okay
[Applause]
cheers oh my God honestly I
can't
it's
so oh if I had honey or something
maybe it's so is there a word you can
use to describe it chrisy it's so oddly
tart for so
early that's a good idea Drew sucking on
a fig if you'd like that well here's the
deal Drew lost Chrissy lost with her but
guess what any everyone in our audience
is going home a winner
you're all getting a
$100 gift card from the fondue
restaurant The Melting Pot we can keep
it cheesy It One S well guess
what luckily I have one thing that I
think can take our pain away Chrissy I
want to do some couch time with you some
girl talk with you absolutely we have
the most coveted couch on planet Earth
right now it is the actual one from the
Calvin inin shoot with hottie Jeremy
Allan white people have de the one
remind me the George cza cou right yes
well should we do a little girl talking
on the infamous couch all right here we
go be right
there this is my first share to him oh
yeah I like it yeah no we I know I know
oh sorry we're just girl talking already
we got the party started in the
commercial break we are back with the
incredible Chrissy Tegan
everybody I am such a fan of your
cookbooks too I think that they
were a a very permission giving and sort
of changing of the industry thank you
their sexy fun life lived in them but
it's your flavor profiles and recipes
like the ground beef stuffed in the
Cucumber yes that's my mom soup I know
um I'm going to my mom actually just
moved to Thailand the great pepper
Tepper herook too she yeah her cookbook
is so beautiful so wonderful but she
just a couple weeks ago moved to
Thailand fully moved and is living her
best life she still has so much energy
in her she loves her team of girlfriends
that she has and she's just flourishing
and I wanted to see that for her pepper
Got Her Groove Back pepper is getting
her groove back yes oh my she really is
yeah she's a single lady um my dad has a
girlfriend and so she's out on the prowl
she's on the app so if anyone comes
across her she is obsessed with being
able to show people she's so proud of
Thailand she loves being a tour guide
you know how White Lotus is filming in
Thailand now I do she's trying to get
like any kind of assistant job on White
Lotus if anyone out there is looking for
a trans if you're
listening um okay this is a weird pivot
but um okay speaking of getting one's
groove back um I feel like everybody got
some Groove put into their soul on this
like couch with Jeremy Allen White it
reminds me of the George castanza
couch so this is it like
cuz it's it's a vintage couch and
generated over 35 million views um it
generated also $12.7 million in media
exposure in just two days um and this
couch is being sought after and it's
like we're sitting on it we're sitting
on it I mean it makes me like want to
pose wait by the way how should I pose
on this couch oh I don't know was never
my friend ooh I
mean is
it not sure what this is doing for
anybody oh he likes you oh what a sweet
baby he's so sweet this is the only man
in my bed this is all you need right I
know I wake up every day with four
animals in my bed and I feel so whole oh
my God I also have do you have four dogs
I have two dogs four cats a snake fish
and a bearded dragon a bearded dragon
named still down here talking to you I
know by the way that felt so right and
wrong and right um I was like I've never
done this upside down before this is new
looking up at you your husband came here
and sing I know to Jeremy it's the
cutest
[Applause]
thing with rose petals and there there's
Jeremy with rose petals getting serenad
by none other than John Legend he never
does that to our bearded dragon which we
don't know the name of anymore so we
don't know if it's a boy or it's a it
was a boy now it's a girl we found out
so we now we call her beauty I don't
know now does John like I mean your
husband is one of the greatest living
songwriters and such a
kind he speaking of like Jeremy Allen
White and sexy what is go he has the
hottest chest and he's always exposing
it my gosh like look at him I know he's
he's my bear he's my baby bear he's so
God he loves a print now he just won't
won't stop with the pants when he like
gets dressed and like looks in the
mirror does he is he like oh he does the
face he does like this like weird like
lip sucking thing that miles does too
now like when he looks in ever since he
started the voice really his style
really like became poppier and like much
much more inyour face and yeah I find
myself going out with them sometimes I'm
like we know you're John Legend already
you don't have to wear this much print
on print on print on print I'm I'm I'm
here for it he's so nice he was he is
really kind as good and pure as you
could imagine a man to be like he really
is that good everyone's like oh is he so
nice I'm like yes he's nice he's sweet
he's kind but he's like brilliant I hate
saying all of this but his levels of
empathy and uh and and towards for other
people and is just like a like a I don't
know like a sponge of like kindness and
goodness you seem like such an amazing
family so much love it's easy honestly
humor goodness support yeah what is
something that you value for
longevity we will be right
[Music]
back what is something that you value
for longev it um honestly I think we're
always very thoughtful if we are arguing
about something he doesn't argue often
honestly and I think one of our fights
is actually that he doesn't fight enough
like he like sometimes you know when the
passion is there and you want him to get
riled up about something and and it's
just not there but he brings me down to
a level where I'm like okay I'm being
overreactive right now I'm being a
little crazy I'm very anxious person I
get very nervous I'm very tough on
myself um and so for someone to come in
and be the you know the calming force
and all of that is really important so
honestly my only I I I can't I don't
even have like advice or it's just like
I found someone really great and right
now like the battle I think our our
biggest battles are just like trying to
get our kids to get along together and
like so that part of it is so fun seeing
us grow into parents like we were kids
when we got together now we have so many
kids and then seeing him as a dad and
seeing him how busy he is and how he
will come home from work and play
football and they will ask anything of
him like and and he will be there and
he'll do it and it's a actually when we
had our we like celebrated our 10th
wedding anniversary and in my speech it
would had really driven me crazy that on
our wedding day I I hadn't written my
own vows because I was so nervous and so
I made sure to write my vows and then I
was like I looked down at his family and
I just like graciously thanked them for
creating such an incredible being was
that so corny
no it's
amazing thank you okay speaking of
couples I was watching the episode of um
your and David Chang's new show it's so
good it's so good it really so wonderful
Chrissy and Dave Dy out and it feels a
lot like your cookbooks in the way that
it feels really real life yes oh we have
a clip actually here take a look cool
what is this meaty Guy this is this is
the wise guy it's halfhazard thrown on
clunky as he says I'll be honest I don't
understand at all by the way if he
explains it to you again next week it'll
be totally
different you want to have a slice of
have you been eating anything I know
will you please enjoy this one with us
why am I why am I ever going to eat a
pizza that doesn't have smoked
mozzarella on it ever again it's so and
David Chang he's the best you always
surround yourself in such elevated Colin
company and right company really do you
know what is always the most flattering
compliment I get is when someone new
meets us or comes into our home they
always say that we are surrounded by
really really good to the core people
and I love that and I've known David for
20 years and being able to go our first
dates were at Momo fuku noodle bar and I
fell in love with him yes we used to
live across from the Hell's Angels in
the East Village and we would just walk
up the Street up First Avenue and get to
sit at the kitchen it was my first taste
of like an open kitchen and to be able
to and his flavors that he used like
made me like just so proud to be Asian
and and also like the fusion of flavors
that he does it was just he changed the
game too he was a game Cher true true
Game Changer Game Changer yes well your
new show is just just D out on Christy
and Dave die now it's too easy it's so
[Music]
good
okay we are back with chrisy tan can we
try couch confessions okay in honor of
Jeremy Allen way I'm sorry Douglas I
have to just you know what you just stay
there so calm it's like this is nothing
to him his tongue they're all Hostess
based questions and they happen to be on
Tidy whes in honor of Jeremy Allen White
and the couch okay you want to ask each
other yes okay you go first what was the
last big lie you told
oh
oh can you say it I know isn't that you
know it's funny actually well it's I
this is not a really fun answer but um
and that's the worst preface I've ever
done in my life buckle up this isn't
going to be fun my daughter thought she
caught me doing something that I used to
do but I've since not done and she was
like you did this thing and I was like
actually I haven't and I didn't and I
felt so good to be able to not have to
lie to her and it was just a bad habit
that I had that I finally kicked and
well good for you thank you and I didn't
have a li she didn't do it okay what's
one thing you pretended to like because
most people do oh gosh power of
influence one thing I pretended to like
um
people certain people um certain shows
but now like I used to be able to like
say them and then then I'll get like a
text from like the director and be like
just or I'll run into them somewhere and
that's that's hell I know it's a
dangerous World it really is and the
world is small yeah just shut up the
message I'm getting yeah I used to just
I I used to just be able to be like oh
this show this episode's stunk and no
not anymore oh my gosh the world the
Tipping Point happened now but and yet
no one else got the memo it's as hot as
hell out there in this town square okay
next question um oh there's more I love
it okay I'll go I'll go first uh does
your mind ever wonder during oh does
your mind ever wonder if it's during sex
during sex yes yeah all the time really
yeah where does it go anywhere
um is the door locked
uh
um uh oh is like is my spray tan coming
off on like so much this a thank you
this is
why exactly it that's exactly it I it's
been so long since I've had sex but
recently in a yoga class they were like
and don't think about what you're having
for lunch after this and it I was
literally like where am I going to go
for lunch after this and I was like oh
God
um okay what's your question one more
I'm throwing it to you this is about you
what was your sexual Awakening oh oh
honestly I just re-watched
um um the Aerosmith Crazy video oh with
Alicia Silverstone and uh Liv Tyler
Tyler yes when I was watching them I was
thrown back into like oh my gosh this is
just like so Uber hot and beautiful and
they were just like just young and is
having a good time then there's like
this really creepy guy in it like if you
watch it now it doesn't exactly hold up
to The Changing Times but at the time I
remember watching that video and being
like like this is hot mine's Elvis yeah
it's Elis all the way ever since I was
little the second I saw him that was it
for me did you tell Riley that and um
yes and everything I like I'm so Elvis
obsessed go and like Butler is here in
the building and I'm like freaking out
yes oh my go yes I see he did such an
honor and see his co-star Callum Turner
is here too and I'm so excited and I
feel like I'm going to start blushing
when I talk about all this you see
people like that and you're like that's
an actor like that's a handsome actor
actor actor actor man and I'm so happy
that he was so recognized for it you
know because he deserves all the
attention in the world oh tan thank you
so much for coming here finally we've
been hoping you are coming here since
season 1 we'll be right
back